Vivo y trabajo en Tokio, Japón.
Y soy especialista en investigar sobre la conducta humana
y en aplicarlo para imaginar el futuro de diferentes maneras,
y en diseñar en función de ese futuro.
Para ser sinceros, llevo haciéndolo desde hace 7 años,
y no tengo ni idea de cómo va a ser el futuro.
No obstante, tengo una idea muy aproximada
de cómo la gente se comportará en el futuro.
Éste es mi despacho. Está ahí fuera.
No está en el laboratorio,
y cada vez más lo sitúo en lugares como India, China, Brasil, África.
Vivimos en un planeta de 6300 millones de personas.
Al final de este año unos 3000 millones
contarán con teléfono móvil.
Y se tardará unos 2 años en conectar a los próximos 1000 millones.
Y lo menciono porque
si queremos diseñar para ese futuro,
necesitamos averiguar cómo se comportan esas personas.
Y por esa dirección se conduce mi trabajo
y nuestro trabajo de equipo.
Nuestros investigadores a menudo empiezan con una cuestión muy simple.
Por ejemplo: ¿Qué llevan encima?
Si reflexionan sobre todas las cosas de su vida, sus pertenencias
cuando salen por esa puerta,
¿qué piensan llevarse consigo?
Cuándo miran alrededor, ¿qué tienen en cuenta?
De esas cosas ¿qué se llevan?
Y de esas cosas, ¿cuáles usan en realidad?
Pues es eso lo que nos interesa
porque el proceso de decisión consciente e incosciente
implica que las cosas que llevan consigo, y terminan usando,
tienen algún tipo de valor espiritual, emocional o funcional.
Y francamente, como saben,
las personas están dispuestas a pagar por cosas de valor.
Así que he pasado 5 años de investigación
observando lo que la gente lleva encima.
Miro los bolsos de las personas. Miro sus bolsillos y monederos.
Voy a sus casas. Y lo hago en todo el mundo,
y los seguimos por la ciudad con videocámaras.
Es como acechar con permiso.
Y hacemos todo esto --y volvemos a la pregunta del principio:
¿Qué llevan las personas?
Y resulta que las personas llevan un montón de cosas.
Vale, eso es bastante lógico.
Pero si preguntas a las personas cuáles son las tres cosas más importantes,
a través de culturas, género y entornos,
la mayoría de las personas dirá que las llaves, el dinero,
y si tienen uno, el teléfono móvil.
Y con ello, no afirmo que esto sea algo bueno, pero es así.
Es decir, yo no podría quitarles sus teléfonos.
Probablemente me darían una patada.
Vale, puede parecer algo obvio
preguntarle a alguien que trabaja para una empresa de telefonía móvil.
Pero en realidad la pregunta es ¿por qué?
¿Por qué son estas cosas tan importantes en nuestras vidas?
Y resulta, según nuestra investigación, que esto se reduce a supervivencia.
Supervivencia para nosotros y para nuestros seres queridos.
Las llaves proporcionan acceso a refugio y calor,
también al transporte, cada vez más en EEUU.
El dinero es útil para comprar comida, sustento,
entre sus otros usos.
Y un teléfono móvil, resulta ser una gran herramienta de recuperación.
Si prefieren esta especie de jerarquía de necesidades de Maslow,
estos tres objetos son muy buenos como base
en los niveles inferiores en la jerarquía de necesidades de Maslow.
Sí, también hacen muchas otras cosas,
pero son muy buenos en esto.
Y en especial, en la capacidad del teléfono móvil
de permitir a las personas sobrepasar espacio y tiempo.
Y lo que quiero decir con esto es que
pueden sobrepasar el espacio simplemente haciendo una llamada.
Y pueden sobrepasar el tiempo enviando un mensaje cuando quieran,
y otra persona podrá verlo cuando quiera.
Y esto se aprecia bastante universalmente,
por eso hay 3000 millones de personas conectadas.
Y valoran esa conectividad.
Pero en realidad, pueden hacer estas cosas con PCs.
Y pueden hacerlo en cabinas telefónicas.
Pero el teléfono móvil, además, es personal
y eso además les otorga un punto tanto de privacidad como de comodidad.
No tienen que pedir permiso a nadie,
pueden simplemente hacerlo ¿no?
Sin embargo, para que estas cosas nos ayuden a sobrevivir
tienen que llevarlas encima.
Pero -y es un pero bastante grande- nos olvidamos.
Somos humanos, por eso nos olvidamos. Es una de nuestras características.
Yo creo que una buena característica.
Así que olvidamos, pero también somos adaptables,
y nos adaptamos muy bien a situaciones que nos rodean.
Y también tenemos estrategias para recordar,
y una de ellas se mencionó ayer.
Es bastante simple esta reflexión.
Es en ese momento cuando sales de un lugar,
te das la vuelta y, a menudo, te tocas los bolsillos.
Incluso las mujeres que guardan las cosas en sus bolsos se tocan los bolsillos.
Te das la vuelta, miras hacia atrás hacia ese lugar,
y algunas personas hablan en voz alta.
Muchos lo hacen en algún momento.
Ok, lo siguiente es: la mayoría de ustedes, si tienen una vida familiar estable,
me refiero a que no viajan todo el tiempo y siempre están en hoteles,
pero la mayoría tienen lo que llamamos un "centro de gravedad".
Y un centro de gravedad es donde se guardan esos objetos.
Y esas cosas no se quedan en el centro de gravedad,
pero durante un tiempo gravitan ahí.
Ahí es donde esperas encontrar las cosas.
De hecho, cuando te das la vuelta
y miras dentro de la casa
buscando estas cosas,
es ahí donde miras primero ¿verdad?
Vale cuando realizamos esta investigación,
descubrimos la manera 100% segura
de nunca olvidar nada, jamás.
Y esto se logra, simplemente no teniendo nada que recordar.
(Risas)
Vale, suena como algo que lees en una galleta china de la suerte,
pero en realidad se trata del arte de delegar.
Y desde una perspectiva del diseño,
se trata de entender lo que puedes delegar en la tecnología
y lo que puedes delegar en otras personas.
y en efecto, delegar, si quieres hacerlo,
puede ser la solución para casi todo,
excepto para cosas como las necesidades corporales, como ir al lavabo.
No puedes pedirle a nadie que lo haga por ti.
Y cosas como el entretenimiento,
no le pedirías a nadie que fuera al cine y se divirtiera por ti.
O por lo menos no todavía.
Quizás alguna vez en el futuro lo hagamos.
Quisiera ponerles un ejemplo de delegar llevado a la práctica.
Esto es, probablemente, lo que más me apasiona:
el estudio que hemos realizado sobre analfabetismo
y cómo las personas analfabetas se comunican.
NNUU estima, según los datos del 2004,
que casi 800 millones de personas en todo el mundo no saben leer ni escribir.
Hemos estudiado mucho el tema,
y una de las cosas que observamos es
que si no sabes leer ni escribir
y te quieres comunicar a distancia,
tienes que saber identificar a la persona
con la que te quieres comunicar.
Podría ser un número de teléfono, una dirección de correo electrónico,
una dirección postal...
Es una cuestión sencilla, si no sabes leer ni escribir
¿cómo manejas tu información de contacto?
Y el hecho es que millones de personas lo hacen.
Desde la perspectiva del diseño, no sabemos como lo lograron,
y esto es solo un pequeño ejemplo
del tipo de estudio que realizamos.
Y resulta que los analfabetos son expertos en delegar.
Así que delegan parte de su proceso de tarea a otros,
las cosas que ellos no pueden hacer solos.
Les pondré otro ejemplo de cómo se delega.
Éste es un poco más sofisticado,
es sobre un estudio que hicimos en Uganda
sobre cómo las personas utilizan los aparatos que comparten.
"Sente" es una palabra en Uganda que significa dinero.
Tiene además otro significado, el de enviar dinero para cargar saldo.
Y funciona así:
Digamos que es junio y estás es una aldea rural.
Yo estoy en Kampala y soy el asalariado.
Quiero enviar dinero y funciona así:
En tu aldea solo hay una persona con teléfono,
y éste es el operador de la centralita telefónica.
Y es bastante probable que tengan un simple teléfono móvil en la centralita.
Así que compro una tarjeta prepago como ésta.
Y en vez de usar ese dinero para cargar mi propio teléfono,
llamo al operador de la aldea local
y le leo el número y él lo usa para cargar con dinero su teléfono.
Así que están cargando el valor desde Kampala,
y ahora está siendo cargado en la aldea.
Te llevas un 10% o un 20% de comisión,
el operador de la centralita se lleva un 10% ó 20% de comisión,
y te pasa el resto en efectivo.
Vale, hay dos cosas que me gustan de esto,
la primera es que todo el que tiene acceso a un teléfono móvil,
todo el que tenga un teléfono móvil,
se convierte en un cajero automático.
Lleva servicios bancarios rudimentarios a lugares
donde no hay infraestructura bancaria.
E incluso si pudieran tener acceso a la infraestructura bancaria,
no serían necesariamente considerados clientes viables,
porque no son lo suficiente solventes como para tener cuentas bancarias.
Hay una segunda cosa que me gusta de esto.
Y es que a pesar de todos los recursos a mi disposición,
y de toda nuestra sofisticación aparente,
sé que yo nunca podría haber diseñado algo tan elegante
y tan en sintonía con las condiciones locales como esto.
Y sí, hay cosas como el Banco Grameen y los microcréditos,
pero la diferencia entre esto y eso
es que no hay autoridad central intentándo controlar esto.
Se trata simplemente de innovación callejera.
Y la calle es una fuente inagotable
de inspiración para nosotros.
Y vale, si rompes una de estas cosas, la devuelves a la empresa.
Te dan una nueva.
Probablemente te darán tres nuevas.
Me refiero a compras tres y te llevas una gratis. Ese tipo de cosas.
Si vas por las calle de la India y de China ves este tipo de cosas.
Y ahí es cuando cogen las cosas que se rompen
y las arreglan y los vuelven a poner en circulación.
Esto es de una mesa de trabajo en Ciudad Jilin, en China,
y puedes ver a gente desmontando un teléfono
y armándolo de nuevo.
Hacen un manual de ingeniería inversa.
Es una especie de manual del hacker,
y está escrito en chino y en inglés.
También lo escriben en hindi.
Te puedes suscribir.
Hay institutos de formación donde forman a personas
para arreglar esas cosas también.
Pero lo que me gusta de esto es que
todo se reduce a alguien en la calle que cuenta con una superficie pequeña y plana,
un destornillador, un cepillo de dientes para limpiar las cabezas de contacto
porque a menudo hay polvo en las cabezas de contacto.. y conocimiento.
Y todo se mueve en la red social del conocimiento, flotando.
Y me gusta porque desafía nuestra manera de diseñar cosas,
y construir cosas y potencialmente distribuir cosas.
Desafía las normas.
Para mi las calles sugieren muchas preguntas diferentes.
Esto es Viagra que compré en un sex shop clandestino en China.
Y China es un país donde se pueden comprar muchas falsificaciones.
Y se lo que se están preguntando, ¿la probé?
No voy a responder a eso.
Pero miro algo así y considero las implicaciones
de confianza en el proceso de compra,
y miramos esto y pensamos, bueno ¿cómo se aplica,
por ejemplo, para el diseño de... las lecciones de esto
aplicadas al diseño de servicios en línea, a futuros servicios en estos mercados?
Este es una par de calzoncillos de
(Risas)
del Tibet.
Y miro algo así, y sinceramente, ya saben,
¿Porque diseñaría alguien calzoncillos con un bolsillo?
Y veo algo así y me planteo
cómo podríamos aprovechar toda la funcionalidad de cosas así
y redistribuirlas por todo el cuerpo
en una especie de red de área personal,
¿cómo priorizaríamos el sitio para poner las cosas?
y sí, esto es muy trivial pero este conocimiento se pueden aplicar
a ese tipo de redes de área personal.
Y lo que ven aquí es un par de números de teléfono
escritos encima de la choza en la Uganda rural.
Esta no tiene número de casa, tiene números de teléfono.
Así que ¿qué significa cuando la identidad de la gente es móvil?
Cuando la identidad de esos 3000 millones más de personas es móvil, ¿no está fija?
Vuestra noción de identidad ya está anticuada
para esas 3000 millones de personas adicionales.
Así es cómo está cambiando.
Aquí tengo esta foto, que fue con la que empecé.
Y es... es de Delhi.
Es de un estudio que hicimos sobre el analfabetismo,
y aquí se ve un hombre en una tetería.
Pueden ver té sirviéndose al fondo.
Y él es, como ven, un empleado muy pobre,
en la escala social más baja
Y él, de alguna manera aprecia
los valores de LiveStrong.
Y no son necesariamente los mismos valores,
pero una especie de valores de LiveStrong,
para realmente salir, comprarlos
y exponerlos.
Para mi, esto personifica este mundo conectado,
donde todo está entrelazado, y los puntos están --
todos los puntos se unen.
El título de esta presentación es "conexiones y consecuencias",
y es un resumen de 5 años intentando averiguar
cómo será cuando cada persona del planeta
tenga la capacidad de trascender el espacio y el tiempo
de una forma personal y práctica.
Cuando todo el mundo esté conectado.
Existen 4 cosas.
La primera es la inmediatez de las ideas,
la velocidad con la que las ideas se propagan.
Y sé que TED trata sobre grandes ideas,
pero en realidad el punto de referencia para una gran idea está cambiando.
Si pretendes una gran idea tienes que englobar a todo el mundo,
eso es lo primero.
Lo segundo es la inmediatez de los objetos.
Y a lo que me refiero es que estos se vuelven más pequeños
mientras que la funcionalidad a la que puedes acceder se vuelve grande
--cosas como la banca, la identidad--
estas cosas, se mueven muy rápido alrededor del mundo.
Así que la velocidad de la adopción de cosas
se va a convertir en algo mucho más rápido
de una forma que no podemos concebir totalmente,
cuando alcanzas los 6300 millones
y el crecimiento total de la población mundial.
Lo siguiente es que sin embargo diseñamos estas cosas
--las diseñamos cuidadosamente--
la calle las cogerá y averiguará maneras de innovar,
mientras que cumplan las necesidades básicas.
La capacidad de trascender el espacio y el tiempo por ejemplo.
Se innovará de formas que no podemos anticipar.
De maneras que, a pesar de nuestros recursos, ellos pueden hacer mejor.
Esa es mi sensación.
Y si somos inteligentes, miraremos estos artículos que están saliendo,
y averiguaremos una manera de habilitarlos para que informen e infundan
lo que diseñamos y cómo lo diseñamos.
Y lo último es que --realmente el objetivo de la conversación--
con otros 3000 millones de personas conectadas,
quieren ser parte de la conversación.
Y creo que nuestra relevancia y la de TED
es en realidad lograrlo y aprender a escuchar, esencialmente.
Y solo debemos aprender a escuchar.
Así que muchas, muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)